[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work they love and create
incredible relationships I'm John
deloney joined here by George Campbell
and we are taking your calls on work
money life whatever you got going on we
probably have an opinion on it give us a
shout at triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five five two two five it is a
packed audience out there today packed
um and it's good to see everybody let's
go out to John in Greenville North
Carolina what is up John how we doing
man
hey I'm doing well how are you all
excellent my brother what's up
uh okay so two questions um I'm looking
for some advice and a career change
um and I also transition from Whole Life
to term life and I kind of want to know
what to do with the money that they're
going to send back to me
um so I'm 41 I've been in education for
about 17 years in administration at a
Middle School uh can we just stop right
there God bless you dude it's amazing
God bless you man
thank you I have I have a middle
schooler one who lives at my house
wow and I'm trying to administrate that
and God bless you dude incredible thank
you thank you there is no job on Earth
you can't do so there you go all right I
appreciate it go for it
uh yes sir so in listening to the show
I've been listening to the show off and
on but I really made a stronger
commitment back in January this year so
I'm about 121
797 a debt of that it's consumer Dead
about 60 000 and then the mortgage on my
home is about 61 000. so wanting to
expedite you know getting out of debt
but also realizing that I'm pretty much
capped at my salary
um unless I go into being a senior
principal which the working conditions
is worse than what I have now um so I'm
thinking about a career change and
trying to navigate that but so are you
wanting to change careers because of the
income or are you wanting to get out of
an Administration and do me a favor talk
directly into your phone for me
yes sir there you go a little bit of
both a little bit of both
I'm gonna get out because I don't think
it's going where I needed to go
you want to stay in Greenville
yes sir okay what's your current income
um 85 000 a year okay
all right now you said you have a whole
life policy what would you get from that
once you cancel it
yes sir I've canceled it through Xander
and so they quoted me at about 5 400
some dollars and 45 days from when I
canceled it which I think is March of
this year is when I can expect and I
don't really know I know there's going
to be some taxes involved so I'm a
little worried about that too
okay and do you have any other money
right now in savings
uh my emergency fund I'm on baby step
two
okay so you've got a thousand bucks in
the bank
and the rest has been going towards the
debt
yes what is this Consumer Debt is it
student loans
get it lows yes
um and then lose about three credit
cards
and you've been carrying the student
loans for the last 17 years
uh um yes including like the Masters
that I got so it's kind of been a little
bit here and there you've collected some
along the journey
yes okay are you married you have
somebody to pitch in and help or are you
single
single all right looking to be married
but you know
working 12 hours a day it's kind of hard
I am you're impressive well the good
news is making 85 000 can you pay off 60
absolutely
you can be done with this in less than
two years
okay so that's not a I wouldn't change
careers because your financial situation
is on fire I would change careers
because you want to change careers
okay yes sir do you know what you want
to do or do you want to stay in in the
education world or you want something
completely different
I've been kind of looking at some things
in it and I've taken like a little boot
camp course and it was really intriguing
I did well on it
um just a little nervous about jumping
into that because with the entry level
and I need to get certifications and
stuff find me the time to study for that
has also been an issue but yeah I'm
going to tell you something I hate to
say this because I've actually I've been
in a education administrator for most of
my career so I
I think there's an opportunity and it's
going to be a very unpleasant one as
George was pointing out I think there's
an opportunity for 24 months of staying
in your current job even if you just
made one of those chains that you make
when you're a kid of out of construction
paper and you just tear a one off every
month I got 24 of these months and I'm
going to work these long 10 to 12 hour
administrative days and then on
Saturdays and Sundays when I'm not at
games and I'm not running around at
whatever we're doing right at band
ceremonies or whatever I'm gonna start
branching out into some of these this
I.T world and you can do part-time it
work you can do on the side it work and
make no mistake dude in 24 months you're
going to be so tired you're not gonna be
able to form sentences you're gonna be
exhausted but you will have you will
have a paid all this crap off you're not
going to have enough time to go out and
do anything and that's good and you're
going to
have been able to dip your toe in the
water and see if it is the job for you I
just this is just me I may be way out to
lunch I think that is a
that's gonna be a tough toggle from
being somebody that all these kids love
that's you know hey Dr so-and-so or hey
Mr so-and-so who gets to help people and
all of a sudden you transition to just
headphones on zero one one one one zero
zero one maybe maybe you're ready for
that that feels like
um an Educator's fantasy like I just
want no kids and no humans and
especially no parents and I just want a
screen and some headphones that will be
awesome for about two months and then
you'll be frustrated I like what George
has to say man if you clear this up and
begin to think like
do I like teaching do I like education
do I want to go teach the college level
do I just want to get out of the school
district because it's toxic or do I want
to go to private school I think clearing
some of this debt up is going to give
you a cleaner slate to think from does
that sound right
it does yes sir
so following the baby steps we're going
to ignore the Mortgage Debt right now
and just focus on that Consumer Debt and
making 85 000 even if you threw 30 of
the 85 towards the state you're done in
two years so my goal is to do it even
faster than that and do what it takes
cut the expenses work on the side if you
need to maybe even do some I.T side work
to start dipping your toes in that water
but here's what that's going to do for
you once you're debt free you could take
a pay cut you could take an entry level
I.T job making 50 or 60 and make that
work if you're debt free and so that
would be my fuel to get debt for even
faster is knowing that's on the other
side and John we also run into people
all the time who are debt free and
they're working at a pretty toxic job
and then they have this newfound power
this new found Freedom that when the
boss says hey I need you to to I know I
didn't tell you I'm so sorry it's Friday
afternoon at four o'clock I need you to
be here tomorrow morning at 8 A.M for
the to open up the doors for the band
concert and you just look at them and
you go I'm not doing that like I've
already got plans I'm not going to be
here and you owe nobody anything
and it's basically I call I call you I'm
put your cards on the table you're not
gonna fire me and they don't they find
somebody else they just been picking on
you and you've just been saying yes
because you're you think you're 120
Grand in the hole and you can't breathe
man you clear that stuff up and your job
suddenly the light comes on a little bit
and it becomes more of something that's
gonna make you happy not something
that's just killing you John I'm gonna
send you our friend Ken Coleman's get
clear assessment to help you with the
career side and every dollar plus to
help you on the financial side when it
comes to making a plan for these dollars
love it love it love it thanks for the
call John Triple Eight two five five two
two five this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and next week's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today and
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
welcome back this is the Ramsey Show
triple eight eight two five five two two
five we're talking money mental health
marriage life whatever's going on in
your life give us a shout triple eight
eight two five five two two five I'm
John deloney joined here by George
the great camel wow I forgot that was my
middle name
for asked us to call you so there you go
self-proclaimed well John uh I'm on the
internet and I see this article
and it just I thought I like to grind
your gears and so I think this one might
do that I want to get your take on it
and here's the gist of the story it's my
hot take as the kids say right yes
please never use that term uh you got it
we're done with that okay so this woman
recently gives birth
and her husband demands that she pay the
entire hospital bill herself
now there's more to the story they've
been married seven years she just had
her their first baby three months ago
they split everything in their marriage
50 50 when it comes to finances and
generally keep their money separate
and everything seemed to be going pretty
well until they received a hospital bill
for this birth so here's the deal she
planned to give birth without any
medication but after 24 hours of Labor
decided to do the epidural and when the
bill came her husband expected her to
pay the entire eight grand Bill herself
and when she asked why he said you're
the one who couldn't hold out for a few
more hours and you jacked up the bill
and I shouldn't have to pay for all
these extra requests and then finally if
she wanted luxury she should expect to
pay for it oh my God if you tried that
on Sheila what would happen what hell
would break loose here's the thing I
wouldn't even be I wouldn't know you
wouldn't get the sentence Because by the
time those words left my mouth I would
already be at the gates
and I don't know which set of gate I
would be at if I said something like
this now if you're wondering all the
extra you know what jacked up this bill
well of course the epidural very
expensive uh lactation consultant
Nursery fee extra night stay postpartum
supplies any food she ate so all of that
made the bill go up and so he goes well
that was your decision so you should pay
for that that's not coming out of my
pile of the pot so she ended up paying
the entire bill on her own and she's now
wondering and questioning are her
feelings valid John okay so I had
somebody call my show a few years ago
and here's the question
um it she had a two-year-old and a seven
month old and she was with her boyfriend
and he let her know
um I want to let you know that I'm not
considering you
for the role of my wife but two things
you're gonna have to a get my house back
in order because this place is a wreck
like you're just not taking care of the
house and B you're gonna have to get
your body back because let's be honest
you let that sucker go and when you get
that back and she and here's the deal
she was calling me to ask
how she could be more disciplined and I
was like oh honey like oh man
two friends that would not mind going
back to jail what's his address or right
so it's a it's a it's easy when you're
when somebody is is so is gaslighting
you so bad is is so out to lunch you
think you're the start to look in the
mirror and be like oh it must clearly
it's me I'm the problem it's not them
yes they've been very clear that it's
it's not it's not them it's me I'm the
problem yes I
wow wow so this is an abusive
relationship very clearly but it's an
insane relationship and but here's the
thing I do want to call out to there's
uh I don't have 10 million people
listening right now half of you and I
know it's half of you because that's how
much negative negative press we get
I'm never gonna I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna share a checking account I'm not
gonna share bills we split this thing 50
50. this is the end result of that and
if it's not if you're like no no I mean
I would help with the with the baby
where's your line dude when you set up a
my life in your life and we're married
into the same roof this is the root of
that crap that happens right this is
this is the end result down the road of
people who don't say hey we're married
we're in come hell or high water we're
both in on this deal this is that bull
crap like oh sorry bro you should just
held out bro
so he's driving a truck through you he's
like well you should just should have
just hung up man I don't know how this
man is still alive truthfully what an
idiot so I don't know I mean truthfully
I don't know if the marriage is going to
survive no if this is how it continues
if this is the attitude towards it and
we know that divorce and money fights
are one of the leading causes uh money
problems and money fights leading cause
of divorce another leading cause of
divorce made sense when you look at
being married to an idiot that's another
one or absolutely more a poor choice was
made at some point
but we teach people that you should
combine finances 100 when you get
married
no earlier but as soon as you're married
combined finances your team it's we it's
not well that's your bill so well I'll
cover electricity you cover the wad I I
got the food last month when we ate out
that's an insane way to live if you
wanted a roommate don't get married is
that simple yes
if you want to go back to being
roommates you can do that and by the way
for the first time in uh Ramsey show
history we're gonna add a few other
recommendations husbands don't look at
your wife and say an epidural is a
luxury you could have waited a few more
hours don't ever say that ever never say
that
um lactation consultant not a luxury not
a luxury here's a here's the thing
gentlemen in case you don't know this
babies
and uh have to eat they have to eat
um here's another one Nursery fee so
babies can stay in the room with you is
it insane that hospitals charge that yes
it is but
um I don't know throughout all of human
history until about 60 years ago babies
always slept in the same room with their
new parent like dude don't be insane
don't be George man I told you it was
gonna grind your gears this is the
opposite of hemorrhoids this has got me
so puckered up I want to know this guy I
want to find this guy wow we went from
visual to visceral thank you John I I
can't I'm I'm just trying to imagine how
this would go in my house and I just
wouldn't here's what would happen you
and and probably Dave and maybe Rachel
there'd be a couple of y'all at this
desk and there'd be a box of tissues and
you'd just be saying like John's dead
John's dead and uh he won't be doing the
show he had a good life he had a good
life but man he sure was stupid when it
came to one of his children being born
wow
all right that's enough of that John
well thanks for I need some good news
thanks for making my day uh let's see if
Erica can help us out let's go to Erica
in Cleveland Ohio what's up Erica
yes Save Me
save me
hi my name is Erica I'm from Cleveland
how are you doing today John and George
we're making it we're making it hey
we're kind of up against the clock so
right into your question
okay
um that was an accident in January the
insurance company or the other person
found me at fault and they said
um sent it to Corrections for five
thousand dollars and I was trying to
figure out what can I do because I don't
even know where to begin
so you were in a wreck
um you were at fault and they had the
five thousand dollar judgment against
you and I'm assuming you don't have five
thousand dollars to pay
no
okay and they've all it happened in
January and they've already sent it to
collections yeah yes they
sent me a letter
what
um this week actually Four collections
already okay they sent me the letter for
us and I was at fault last week and sent
me to collections without her for
Corrections this week it may not be
collections yet it may just be like a
they want payment like if they just now
yeah who yeah who wrote the letter
uh I don't know it just said some kind
of collection agency okay
um I would call them back
and
I would be very direct with I just got
this piece of paper that says I'm at
fault I've had no time to review it I
haven't had time for my attorney to
review it I just got this thing and then
all of a sudden you guys are calling me
for five thousand dollars which I don't
have right now I'm gonna have to make
arrangements I'm gonna have to call you
back
um and then you're gonna have to sit
down and come up with a plan for this
five thousand bucks
um if there's a judgment there's a
judgment do you have any other debt yeah
um that's that's it that's doing laws in
the house no okay and I don't really
know how much my student loans are
exactly well we got some homework to do
Erica make sure let's figure out exactly
how much we owe let's list it all out
and let's take care of this collections
before it accrues any penalties or
interest or fees but if you owe it let's
just make a plan to pay it I'm gonna
send you Financial Peace University it's
going to walk you through our proven
plan to get out of this mess and start
building for the future instead but uh
it's five grand and it feels like a lot
right now one day you're gonna look back
and go that sucked remember that yes but
you gotta gotta gotta pay it don't
ignore it because it's gonna double and
triple on you then you're gonna get in a
bit the only way yeah to pay it off
that's right this is the Ramsey Show
foreign
[Music]
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is
budget-friendly biblically based Health
cost sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
C of chm could be right for your family
learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
this is the Ramsey Show triple eight
eight two five five two two five is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five let's go out to Charlie in Virginia
Beach what's up Charlie
hi so I bought my house this past
November and after finding Dave I
realized that it was a very poor
financial decision that's a big one
yes my boyfriend and I are considering
getting married and I'm just wondering
if I should save some money to be able
to sell my house as I'm in baby step two
how much debt do you have
um 395 is the mortgage and I have 81 in
student loans
okay when do you plan on getting married
um probably before next year 2024. has
he even proposed yet
we have talked oh Charlie they all talk
the old talk it could be 2029
no I promise it's not
oh sounds like she knows when we don't
there's an ultimatum in place John uh
yes he's also listening on the radio
right now well he's he's done on the
ball here just stop waiting around okay
so what makes you want to sell this
house that's a very big decision is just
is the mortgage way too much
comparatively to your take-home pay
it's astronomical wow give me a number
here what's your takeover 24.
um I take home I take home about 30
under 8K
so about 8K and the mortgage payment is
how much
2524 okay
and we have a COA of 180 a month okay on
top of that so we'll include that in
numbers
so you are I mean that's is that on a 30
year
it is a 30-year okay so it's like 31
percent
I think
so we're looking at over 30 probably
closer to a third of your take-home pay
which is a lot it's not on fire I
thought you're gonna tell me it's 50 60
of your take-home pay
and if you get married his his salary
comes on top of that too right
yes so
the question is what is your household
income versus your debt
um like us combined right now we're just
looking at Charlie solo
oh it's it's the AKA month
your so that's your take-home pay
yeah and how much debt do you have total
81k and is that all student loans oh no
with a with a mortgage it's 476k
together we're just looking at the
Consumer Debt so you have 81 000 student
loans
yes okay
now with your take-home pay you could
pay this off on your own you're making
about a 100K take home almost
and so could you take you know 40 Grand
a year and throw it at the stat and be
done in two years especially if you're
married inside of that you're going to
have combined incomes you're gonna have
a bigger shovel to throw at this debt
you see is he bringing debt with him
no he's a lot smarter than me oh does he
have a house
he does okay so what what's the plan if
you guys get married would you sell this
one anyways
I would want to sell my house because he
has a better house oh okay I have a town
Stone he has a real home and how long
wow shots fired Charlie shots fired I
love a town home
okay so either way you're going to sell
this house down the line
yes my gut tells me we can sell it when
the time comes to sell it because right
now you're gonna sell it and then rent
somewhere in Virginia Beach right
um yes that would be the plan and if you
sold it what would you net profit after
all the fees
I wouldn't profit anything I would have
to save to sell it because it's only
appraised at 3.99 so you'd be underwater
on this thing
yeah yeah so it's it's not really doing
you any favors other than getting rid of
your mortgage payment which is just
going to be replaced with rent
and so I don't I don't think the house
is the problem right now uh I think it's
getting on a budget and seeing if we can
even increase the income and maybe we
can get rid of this debt before marriage
that'd be a cool goal
that's what I want to do to be able to
cash flow the wedding start our marriage
off completely debt free you move into
his place we have a big shovel now we
can start attacking the house I like
that plan
you listening David okay he's listening
but hey but here I want to tell you this
Charlie and this is not
um John and George Debbie downers okay
the Temptation here is to say okay we
have a plan that's going to be a
two-year plan and inside that two-year
plan we're gonna move into his house
we're gonna sell my house we're going to
get married and we're gonna live happily
ever after
the reason we tell folks don't play
house
there's the moral sideways move that
over there's a math problem here okay
and so
the number of of relationships right
where you are that don't end up getting
married or something comes up or it
becomes like let's just wait I want to
wait another year and then another year
it's it's lots and lots and lots and
lots of them
so as hard as this is I want you to do
two things at the same time I want you
to make plans for the future right
you'll continue down you'll talk about
marriage make him propose to you in the
right way and do all that fun stuff and
I want you operating as though you are
on your own
okay absolutely and do both at the same
time but that means
man it may come time to to
you may need to get rid of this house or
you want to get rid of this house but
don't blame Dave and don't blame this
marriage for it let's do it when the
time is right in the right order right
when you're get married we're gonna
we're gonna move in together cool now we
gotta get rid of these places there's
gonna be a lot less pressure that way
then suddenly you sell this place and I
guess that's got to move in or I got to
get an apartment and it gets all wonky
and everybody gets sideways does that
make sense
yes do it the right order but good for
you and David get on the ball this
weekend what are you waiting for
poor David no no poor David he's
listening right now go he can't even
defend himself he's probably I plan on
it John all right sorry if I ruined it
David George I did that one time I had a
former student of mine I was walking out
of a restaurant and a former student of
mine was sitting at a just at a booth
um and I slid into the booth and there
was a woman sitting across from him and
I looked at at her and him and I was
like what are you doing and he
introduced me to her and I was like are
you with him and she's like yeah I
looked at him and said you're ridiculous
you're gonna let her get away you're
just messing her I haven't seen him
forever you're just messing around
screwing around and she's gonna leave
because you won't don't have the courage
to just get married I was just I had
never met her I've just been just
trolling just absolutely trolling and he
looks at me and he looks at her and he
reaches under his leg throws the ring
down on the dinner table and goes well
you ruined that one deloni and like oh
no wow
that's how that's their proposal story
and I was like I think it's probably
time for me to go sorry yeah never again
never don't ever let John slide into a
booth if you're trying to propose that
is correct a very specific scenario that
applies to almost no one but it does
provide it does it does apply to David
and Charlie David needs to get on the
ball here
um let's see here let's run out real
quick to Peter in buildings Peter we're
right up against the clock my brother so
let's get right to your question
can you hear me yes sir get right to
right to the question
okay so my wife and I are both 26 years
old and we got married last year and
since then we've paid off uh 42 000
worth of cars awesome and have money to
pay off 75 000 although the students Wow
way to go man we haven't paid it it's
just a high yield savings account
because
um we want to see what happens with this
decision but we're ready whenever it
happens and so now we have no debt but
our mortgage and so we're maxing out our
401ks she's already maxed hers out to 15
and I just recently became self-employed
and I've heard you guys talk about
there's been some changes with Ross um
IRAs recently for people that are
self-employed and that's the route I'm
looking at going I know the regular Ross
only have a 6 500 limits annually like
as far as contribution limits and I'm
wondering is is that the best option to
go with or are you solo no employees
no employees yep okay my guess and this
is a hunch I want you to look into is
that the solo 401K would be your best
bet and you can only do that if you have
no employees traditional one uh you can
do a Roth solo 401K as well but that
will have giant contribution limits you
can there's a total of 66 Grand cap for
2023 because you can contribute as the
employee and the employer
oh okay so yeah I was thinking I just
couldn't see it on on E-Trade so I'll
I'll go back and look at that do your
homework on the Roth solo 401K you can
get in touch with one of our smartvester
Pros to walk you through this to help
you set this up but it's an incredible
tool for those that are self-employed
you don't have to retire broke if you're
an entrepreneur that's for sure way to
go Peter you and your new spouse are
crushing it that's incredible hey this
is the Ramsay show triple eight eight
two five five two two five give us a
shout we'll be right back
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
every time I talk about this upcoming
event I get more excited because it's
going to be incredible money in marriage
is back and this time instead of just
one night it's going to be an entire
weekend October 19th through 21st this
is months away
so you got time to save up for it join
Rachel Cruz and me for the money and
marriage getaway and spend an entire
weekend unplugged from your day-to-day
life and simply focusing on your
marriage one thing I've seen across the
country where I'm traveling or doing my
show is over the last three or four or
five years couples have become roommates
couples have become great co-managers of
their house and they have lost intimacy
they have just gotten sideways with one
another and it's so hard to find a
bridge back even when that bridge feels
like it's only two inches away and
that's what this weekend is for we're
going to cover things like money and
budgeting with your spouse we're going
to talk about Connections sex and
intimacy will get you planning for your
future together and this isn't what you
think of when you think of a marriage
conference not just going to be you
sitting there with a notebook being a
nerd you're going to learn a ton but
we're also going to give you and your
spouse time together throughout the
weekend to reflect and discuss what
you're on what you're learning and
actually come up with a real game plan
to take home with you Rachel Cruz and I
will be right there to coach you along
the way and answer your questions and we
have some incredible surprises that
we'll also be a part of this weekend we
can't wait for you to be there if you're
listening to this and it sounds like
something you and your spouse need I
want you to talk to your spouse about
this because listen tickets start at
6.99 which is a deal it's Madness for a
weekend uh marriage Retreat getaway and
this is going to be an incredible
experience go to
ramsesolutions.com
events to save your spot that's
ramseysolutions.com
events to save your spot can't wait for
that John my wife needs this she needs
to be at this event listen okay that's a
great point if you just heard that
announcement that that announcement and
you think my spouse really really need
to deal elbow do not say it like that
say Hey I would like us to go to
Nashville on a trip together to a really
fun cool marriage conference so that we
can get even better
not that's the spirit you know what you
need honey you need you need marriage
couns you'll learn how to be a better
person and this is going to be fun most
marriages like it can be heavy and you
guys will get real but it's also very
fun it's you and Rachel it'll be heavy
but it'll be fun too it'll be fun too
and um it will not be weird that you and
Whitney are in the audience we'll be
there will you can I get a discount
absolutely not okay
let's go out to Grand Rapids Michigan
and talk to John hey John what's up man
hey guys how are you today good good
good what's happening
good hey John to start off wanted to say
thanks your show played part and saving
my marriage so appreciate that oh man
that very cool that means the world to
me dude thank you so much
you're welcome hey but Lauren Cohen
today
um
I am uninsurable as far as life
insurance goes
um and so I'm wondering what you guys
suggest as far as protecting my family
without being able to have life
insurance the traditional life insurance
I guess do you have a medical issue
yeah I have uh PTSD from the military
and that pretty much mixes any insurance
company willing to help me
and there's not there's excuse my
ignorance here there's I know about that
with civilians but there's not a program
that the military has to take care of
it's the people who've been taking care
of all of us
not as far as life insurance goes
um
there is a company that specializes in
getting that it's not a thing through
the military but it's a company that
supposedly specializes in getting life
insurance for people like me but they
also denied me wow I I I want this to be
a like a moment of Shame for our country
it's it's embarrassing and on behalf of
all of us I'm sorry I'm I'm truly sorry
I appreciate that and I I know they
didn't buy you a cup of coffee but it's
it's an i as a taxpayer just a regular
knuckleheaded citizen I'm embarrassed
and I'm sorry
I'm sorry man all right I appreciate
that bye do you have any insurance
through your workplace even a small
policy
you could get no okay
um because I I'm just on disability
through the VA I don't I don't have a
workplace okay
but their wife had my wife has a real
small one on me at hers I think it's
only like 30 000 but that's not gonna
help her save the house and everything
else if we if I die yeah the one route
that I could point you to is a
guaranteed issue policy which wouldn't
be a lot probably only up to 50 Grand
um
yeah but it might be an option your best
option really is to kind of become what
we call self-insured to where you have
no debt you get the mortgage paid off
you get a nest egg saved up and if
something happened your your family's
gonna be okay
go ahead go ahead
I'm say that's what we're working at
obviously you can't get there overnight
um we are we're debt free other than our
house but if I got in a car wreck and
died today she wouldn't be able to keep
the house she wouldn't be able to afford
it I just her income you can also look
into mortgage life insurance which is
going to be something similar to where
it would cover only your mortgage
balance
okay and so those are the mortgage
company or those separate
uh insurance companies that do that uh
it would be through a separate insurance
company and you can get in touch with
our friends at Xander to walk you
through your options for something like
that uh have you got in touch with them
yet
I did they denied me I didn't I didn't
ask about the mortgage when I was just
applying for life insurance and they
denied me as well yeah look into
guaranteed issue and mortgage life and
those might be your Best Bets outside of
just becoming self-insured but man I'm
so sorry you're dealing with this we got
to do better so let me say this John um
and you're a beacon of light out there
for folks
um this is one of those situations where
we want it to be different and it should
be different and it's not
right and you as somebody who's been I
mean you know this better than any of us
it shouldn't be this way we don't want
it to be this way and it is and so I
think setting down and say and spending
time being frustrated like I am right
now is not gonna get you like I said
it's not gonna get you a cup of coffee
it's just going to further spin your
tires in the mud and so I would love to
for you and your wife to go through the
mortgage life insurance to go through
this guaranteed issue and then sit down
and say okay here's our reality we're
going to choose reality now and reality
is nobody's coming to save us
and so let's get some mortgage insurance
that we're probably going to pay a
little bit we're probably going to
overpay afford a little bit but it's
going to let us it's a sleep tax we're
both going to be able to sleep and then
we're just gonna have to do things a
little bit differently
um we may have to be a Corolla family
for several years because
um we're going to put a nest egg aside
because this is going to come we're all
going to end up dead we all know this
and there's not a policy for you and so
I think you see what I'm saying there's
there's some empowerment with owning
reality once you get on the other side
of grief you know what I mean
yeah I got you okay I mean that makes
sense and yeah I'm a 04 Tacoma driver so
I got you hey man I'm an 0600 guy so
there we go we can high five
um but hey on uh I'm grateful for you
thank you for your service and thank you
for for loving us in ways that we're
clearly not reciprocating and there's
something powerful about owning reality
here's where we are and and George I
think we all do this in little ways and
big ways and when people call me and ask
me about how to fix my marriage what's
going on with my mental health it's
often there we Swant so badly something
to be different than what it just is I
want my husband to be more engaged I
want my wife to not talk down to me so
much I want my kids to fill in the blank
and we
it's okay to grieve that but man you've
got to get to it's not so what are we
going to do now right and making a list
writing down the things that we can
control the things that we can do which
is we can get out of debt we can live on
a budget we can get rid of that mortgage
once and for all once you do that you
can sleep better at night knowing you've
done everything you can do you put it
all on the Dance Floor going I did
everything I can to protect my family
but especially for veterans John I know
you have a huge heart for vets out there
but we got to do better it's just a
country I can't I can't wrap my head
around it I just can't uh I can't of all
of the excess spending and all of the
nonsense that we throw money around in
this country
I can't for the life of me and I it
George I pride myself on being able to
see the other side of an argument I
think I think that's the that's the mark
of a wise person who can see the your
opponents somebody you disagree with I
know I get why they're there I get it
this is one that that the sacrifices
that that service men and women make and
that their families make because they go
A Year Without mom they go two years
without Mom or Dad and so they're
grinding it out too and the fact that we
don't have a plan to say Hey you put it
all out there for our country and for
men and women that you will never meet
we got you we've got you and we don't
have that we don't have that you get a
pamphlet and a high five and uh go get
them and I just I just is enraging if if
let me say this to the veterans out
there if I'm wrong please put into the
chat here where this where John can go
get some some help if there's services
that I don't know about please let us
know hey that's hour one in the books
here on the Ramsey Show we'll see you
again real soon we'll be right back
hey it's John deloney co-host of the
Ramsey show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the Ramsey show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com show
foreign
[Music]
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studio
it's the Ramsay show live from Franklin
Tennessee where we help people build
wealth do work they love and create
incredible relationships I'm John
deloney joined here by one of the
greatest humans he's ever lived George
Campbell and we are taking your calls on
life money relationships marriage
whatever you got going on we probably
have an opinion give us a buzz at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
the call is completely free triple eight
eight two five five two two five we're
not supposed to talk about him but let's
go out to Bruno in Lincoln what's up
there Bruno how sick are you of that hey
what's up what's up guys how are you
good hey are you sick of the don't talk
about Bruno jokes because I'm just gonna
keep making them oh yeah yeah I hear
that a lot hey my name rhymes with a
with a bad lunch meat so same team all
right so what's up dude
um my question is uh is it better to
save only for a 20 down payment uh to go
ahead and purchase a house or may wait
for the next five years and then buy the
house cash
okay
walk us through the situation so you're
debt free with an emergency fund and now
you're looking to become a homeowner and
you're saying hey in five years I could
pay cash for a three four hundred
thousand dollar home
is that the idea yeah I'm looking at you
50 300 yeah that's the range okay and it
would take you five years to do this
based on your current income
yes all right yes you're correct here's
the way I look at this and John may have
a different opinion I get worried about
waiting five years because we saw what
the housing market did the last five
years and so the house that you're
looking at that's 250 today could be 400
five years from now and all of a sudden
you're so excited you save 250 and now
you're still 150 shy
you see what I'm saying so it's a moving
goal post and so what I like to do is
just using the Ramsay parameter saying
hey if I did a 15-year fixed rate where
the payment was no more than a quarter
of my take-home pay what would it take
to get there and that number may be 25
down it may be 40 down but I I don't
know that I would personally wait five
years to become a homeowner if you're
financially ready
I see yeah okay it's an awesome goal to
have because you're also you're also
paying rent too on top of it yeah yeah I
would say we're not paying like a huge a
month for rent is only 1300 bucks uh
we're fine where we are and uh it's it's
kind of a tough decision because
whenever I'm thinking on interest rate
how much am I going to be paying
interest uh even if I if I pay principal
early
but here's the thing burnt out number
one you can always refinance later let's
say the rates magically drop back to
three percent we're all high-fiving you
can always refinance later and number
two
your goal should be to pay off that
house as soon as possible which is going
to save you probably six figures in
interest
so if you pay that house off let's say
you bought it in the next year and you
took the next four years to pay it off
well now you only paid five years of
Interest instead of what people normally
pay which is 30 years of interest at a
higher rate okay yeah so approach the
numbers and I still think it's an
awesome goal to pay cash but generally
we'd say hey if you can't save up and
pay cash for it within a few years it's
just a long time to wait while the
housing market keeps appreciating and
shifting
I see okay and let's say if I if I go
ahead even though I can paint early is
it better to come up with a 30 years
mortgage or a 15 years 15 only
and then you be about the business of
paying that thing off like a five year
seven year loan
that's great and you'll be better off
you'll be building Equity you're
basically locking in that housing price
and then building equity and paying that
thing off very quickly Bruno are you
married
yes I'm married is she sweating you down
for a house yep
um I could say it again is she sweating
you down for a house
uh no I had that's that's what happened
my wife just started working and now
we've finally we're going to breathe
financially and we can start building up
these uh the saving accounts so we can
start looking at a house love it yeah I
first seen one year and a half we'll be
able to save enough for a 30 or a forty
percent that's incredible my question
yeah that's awesome
yeah I've been waiting my entire life to
that and finally we got to the point
that
um we're we're we're very thankful for
what happened to our life so yeah dude
I'm so proud of you man you guys are in
a great spot and it's let me just say
it's a fantastic goal to pay cash for a
house that's the way we would always
recommend it if we could but we live in
a fallen world and so the only the only
debt we won't yell at you for is a
15-year fixed rate loan let me make that
clearly I thought Dave said that's bad
it is we don't like it but we understand
that in today's world if we said you can
only pay cash for a house we would have
zero listeners left on the show these
people are insane that's right let's go
to Jason in Pennsylvania what's up Jason
uh good afternoon guys how are you great
how are you man not too bad so quick
question I'm going through some of the
steps that you guys put out there and
right now I'm sitting around forty five
thousand dollars in debt that will be
paid off in a maximum of four years with
if I continue doing the payments but I
also have 65 000 in classes
um the capital gain would be fifteen
thousand
um where the capital gain tax I would
pay on it roughly 2500. okay that makes
sense to sell off that stock to cart to
eliminate that bet or is it it makes
perfect sense I would do it yesterday
all right and I say I've done this Jason
when I was in debt I had some old I had
a few stocks from Apple not nearly what
you have but it helped me pay off debt
and I've never looked back and you can
look at the numbers and go well what the
stock would have been but man single
stocks number one are super volatile and
that money is way better spent freeing
you up instead of doing this for the
next four years and you're still alive
interest yep yeah yes I yeah I'm 100
George any stocks I'd sell them and get
about it set aside the money for those
taxes but man 2500 bucks in taxes to be
debt free today and still have almost 20
grand left over done that's your
emergency fund too I mean you just skip
baby steps one two and three just
LeapFrog that's right hey um before we
head into commercial break
it means a lot to people who have no
idea who we are when they are scrolling
around on YouTube and you have hit the
Subscribe button you've left a five star
review it pops up in their feed it sends
this thing up into the magical wizard
algorithms and it gets the show in front
of more people who are sitting at home
with their face in their hands and
little kids running around they don't
know how they're going to pay their
bills
not asking for money not asking for
y'all to buy any of our stuff like what
we're asking you to do is hit the
Subscribe button it doesn't make us it
doesn't give us any more money it
doesn't make us all feel better it puts
this show in front of other people it's
a zero cost way for you to help out your
neighbors and to begin to take into our
own hands this financial mess that our
country is in there is not going to be a
savior and a white horse on this one
we're gonna have to decide as neighbors
how to do this and if you've always
wondered why don't more people just do
the Dave Ramsey play a lot of people
don't know about it and so if you hit
the Subscribe button if you hit uh go to
Spotify go to Apple hit the Subscribe
button if you leave your five star
reviews it just kicks it up and puts the
show in front of more people and and
um it's more people that can get get
help and George I've never in my life
would have imagined that I was asking
people to hit the Subscribe button yeah
generally you're doing it for validation
this is at a very pure motives and
intentions that he really just wants
impact exactly that's growth John I'm
proud of you I I it's it's such an easy
way to help out your neighbor these days
it really is hit subscribe hey this is
the Ramsay show triple eight eight two
five five two two five we'll be right
back
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com now
and save 45 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
[Music]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five this is the Ramsey Show I'm John
deloney joined here by George Kimmel
we're taking your calls on your mental
health your marriage your money
whatever's going on in your life give us
a shout triple eight eight two five five
two two five and George I am usually not
correct but this time I was whoa this
time I was does your wife know about
this she's going to be ecstatic I'm
going to keep it to myself I need to put
this one in my back pocket just in case
I need it at a later date because you
usually save that as the great Social
Distortion said I am wrong okay so New
York Times comes out in uh a couple
couple days ago the New York Times the
Dirty Little Secret of credit card
reward programs now for years I've been
saying
they work they absolutely do work and
people always call us and like oh you're
telling me that you don't take free
flights and they for sure do if you're
just swiping the card I got a buddy who
puts a hundred percent of his life on
these cards everything on the card so
that and he pays off every month and he
just does it for the for the free free
miles or free whatever sure that's a
real thing that happens now most people
don't pay it off every month and they're
like no I was just going too bro and
they don't but fair enough there are
people who do
and my buddies were always surprised
that I didn't participate and I wasn't
me trying to take a moral High ground or
anything like that
but I didn't want to participate in this
program because I knew that these credit
card companies are not my friend they
don't like me they're not hooking me up
because I'm hooking them up it's not
like yeah bro let's do this we're in
this together I'll buy some stuff you
give me free flights that's not how it
works somebody is paying for my flights
and as I dug into it a few years ago it
appeared to me
that the single mom with three kids who
can't float the price of eggs and the
increase in gas prices and the natural
gas prices she was paying for my flights
because she was having to put the stuff
on a credit card conceivably to survive
and so my free flights were being paid
for by people who had way less and were
struggling to to make it and turns out
who was right turned into studies and
data that's incredible this is why okay
tell us about this okay so the you know
it goes on to talk about hey your these
swipes you're using to get first class
airfare and trips and all your Awards
it's it's not from nothing the credit
card perks for educated usually Urban
Pros are subsidized by people who have
less so poor consumers are ultimately
footing the bill and in 2022 a Federal
Reserve data
show that the cost of rewards as a share
of total transaction volume on these
credit cards increased 25 percent from
2015 through 2021 and so what's
interesting John is the data was so
clear in this study it showed that 15
billion dollars in reward value move
from the poor to the rich from the
unsophisticated folks who couldn't pay
their bills on time to the affluent
wealthy and no normal people go well
yeah that's how the system is set up
John
so I'm just going to take advantage of
that why would I not but here's what's
Wild a lot of the people that come at us
going John's I can't believe John's
trying to use this moral angle to say
it's not coming from people who have
less than it's coming from swipe fees
from the businesses
in interchange fees and my annual fees
but I looked at Capital ones they put
their shareholder reports out every year
and in Q4 of 2022 it turns out that
two-thirds of their credit card Revenue
came from interest and fees not from The
Interchange not from the other fees
interest so two-thirds is blood diamond
money yeah and let's also
it's also easier to to get on on a high
horse and say Well they're just making
dumb purchases and they don't know
if you've ever spent some time with
people on the margins so many don't know
right they haven't been told they're
just trying to claw their way out of the
world that they found themselves in and
they don't know that it's not normal to
roll fees over like this is they don't
know that a 30 APR isn't just the price
of doing life these days and so I
I don't know how people can look in the
mirror and say you know what I'm
comfortable with a single mom trying to
just trying to scratch through life with
her buying my flights because they're
free now like I just can't wrap my head
around to George and the other problem
is we're all paying for this through the
increased cost of goods the United
States has some of the highest credit
card processing costs in the world
typically two to two and a quarter
percent on every purchase and so the
merchants the businesses the small
businesses they have to pass these costs
on to the consumers by charging more for
the products regardless of how you pay
and you see you see some of the local
Merchants that will say here's the price
for if you play with the card oh here's
the cash price it's less and George I it
has I'm sure it's happened to you more
because you're out in the world more
than I am that's true but um I had my
first exchange the other day where I was
at a place I was traveling uh at a
speaking event and I I was out on the
road and they said we don't take cash
here and it was like I'm not gonna do
business with you just just on principle
I'm just not gonna do business with you
wow well the the date is clear here John
lower income consumers are forced to pay
higher prices on the goods they buy but
they rarely receive any benefit from
rewards programs according to the
Federal Reserve and so it's been
tracking all of this and so to put
another way they say credit card awards
are essentially a tax on less affluent
consumers who are much more likely to
pay for the goods with cash debit cards
or standard credit products that accrue
no such rewards so
you know you have a lot of people have a
lot of opinions about this but across
the aisle politically I mean NPR and Vox
and New York Times they're covering the
same thing going hey this isn't innocent
yeah someone is paying for this and it's
either the small business owner or the
single mom but you can't act like this
is just an innocent I'm just going to
rape the rewards your free vacation came
from somewhere and we have to at least
acknowledge that that's right and if you
and and God bless you if you can sleep
at night knowing that um I pay my bills
I do my thing so I if that's that's I
mean if that's if you your conscience
can carry that weight more power and
even if you don't have a conscience
every single piece of data shows that
you spend more when you use a credit
card right every piece of data so
regardless if you're saying hey I'm
going to use every I'm going to use my
card for everything to get these rewards
the chances are you overspent to where
the rewards were negligible right you
you maybe got a thousand bucks in
rewards you spent more than a thousand
dollars than you were if you were gonna
use a debit card on a budget or using
cash so here's here like to me the
Cornerstone rule is opt out of the
system just opt out man this is like
Matrix style stuff but just opt out of
this I haven't had a credit card in 10
years and I can unequivocally say my
life has been better for it no question
not once have I wondered well they've
got five percent cash back on
restaurants this month so I gotta I'm
gonna switch the card I was hanging out
with some guys the other night they're
all personal finance you know influencer
type guys and they're all showing me the
different cards and this one's made of
three inches of metal and I get this
much rewards and I'm like guys you make
millions of dollars how much money do
you get back in rewards they were like I
probably got two grand worth of value
I went so you're playing this game for
two grand worth of value and you make
millions yeah why yeah exactly
it's a crazy I mean when you put it that
way you go is it like real life Dungeons
and Dragons you're getting paid 200 a
month to overspend and play this game
and support this system yeah it's just
not worth it for me I'm out I'm out I
opt out of the system opt out of the
system all right let's go to Silas in
Nashville down the street what's up
Silas how we doing brother
I'm doing good how are you guys doing
excellent what's up man how can we help
okay so um I'm uh 18 years old and I
just got a job making about 75 000 a
year wow congratulations what are you
doing man thank you I'm working on wind
turbines excellent no college degree
needed
very cool all right hey we're up against
the clock it writes your question
brother
so um I'm really trying to look in a way
to save for my kids so that I can take
off work I don't have any kids yet I
don't even have a girlfriend but I plan
on having kids in the future and I want
the first five years or so uh me being
able to spend a majority of time because
studies show that that's really
important uh spending time with your
kids at that age so I want to create a
short-term savings account for five to
ten years in the future but I can't find
really good rates on it like it's
usually like three percent for a bank
and so I was just curious what you guys
thought of like short-term uh savings
where should I put that money
I don't know that savings is the best
route to do this what you're essentially
saying is I want to be a stay-at-home
dad for five to ten years and I don't
want my spouse to work either yeah is
that the idea for five years yeah for
five years yeah I mean you might be
better off looking at some kind of
passive income it's not passive in the
sense that it won't take work but it may
be tough to save up you know four
hundred thousand dollars to live off of
for 10 years in the next five years
right so you can save aggressively a
high yield savings account is good five
years or longer you can invest it into
the market but also live your life man
yeah and having having you might have
read some research but having one of the
parents working full-time is does not
negatively correlate
um childhood development so I don't know
what studies you're reading but
that's not accurate this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
buying a home is one of the biggest
decisions of your life you need a
partner like Churchill Mortgage
Churchill is one of the highest rated
lenders in the country and their Ramsay
trusted because they do what's right for
you Churchill works with you to build a
mortgage the Ramsay way one that doesn't
bust your budget sets you up for
financial success and helps you get out
of debt faster go to
churchillmortgage.com today and get
started
[Music]
thank you
what is up what is up this is the Ramsey
Show triple eight eight two five five
two two five I'm John deloney joined
here by George Campbell and we are
saving the world Listen a lot of you
have questions about taxes we get it
taxes are confusing I think they're
intentionally confusing that's another
podcast to help you get a better handle
on them let's unpack a question from one
of our listeners I'm looking into Ramsay
smart tax and want to know if it offers
forms and online filing for state tax
returns is it as simple to use as Turbo
Tax great question yes you can add a
state return if you need one or you can
just move to Texas or Tennessee all the
information on your federal return is
automatically transferred to your state
forms it could not be much simpler than
that Ramsay tax is easy to use and gives
you access to all major federal forms
and deductions without any up charges
George uh this year I I got a tax person
for the first time ever but the last few
years I've just used Ramsey tax at my
kitchen table and it is so easy and I'm
just not out right there and actually
like doing it at home
um because I like my kids watching like
they get to ask questions and see it
like what's this for me what's this for
me they get to punch in some numbers too
for fun I don't let them touch the
numbers but I do let them know this is
how confusing the government makes it
just to exist when you switch from
another software Ramsay tax can save you
up to 70 percent plus we won't offer you
loans or credit cards most tax programs
are designed just to get you in the door
free tax free tax so that they can sell
you a bunch of crap we're not going to
do that we're not going to put you into
debt that's not how we do things here at
Ramsey if you're ready to file head to
ramseysolutions.com smarttax is just
24.95 right now to file a federal return
39.95 for a state return that's
ramseysolutions.com slash smart tax all
right let's go out to McKinsey in
Orlando Florida what's up McKenzie
Hi how are you great how are you
uh I'm really glad to be talking to you
guys we're here to save the day what's
up
uh so I'm 25 years old
um I have an overwhelming amount of
undergraduate debt and I'm at a point in
my life where I'm hoping to be buying a
house or something but I know that the
advice is to lower the debt before
buying a house
how bad is this this overwhelming debt
um is
235 thousand dollars
wow that is a box of farts on a pony
McKenzie how how like what did you study
I studied electrical engineering okay
did you do a special electrical
engineering like the secret underground
kind
no that's the standard one unfortunately
um you just did it at 60 Grand a year
so I just took a little longer um
generation college student
kind of you know there's a bunch of
reasons why I didn't really feel like I
had like the toolbox starting out and it
took me a while to kind of get into the
group of things sure so what are you
doing now
I'm an engineer good that's a good start
what are you making
I make about 70 000. okay and what other
debt do you have outside of the 235
um I have no other I mean I have like
about a thousand dollars on a credit
card but okay well A1 let's pay that off
and cut up the card
that'll cut that crutch out of our life
and help us get rid of this debt so are
you calling to figure out how best to
pay off the debt yeah I guess I'm
looking at two options uh kind of
waiting for that 20-year forgiveness or
just tearing it down as quick as
possible do you hear what you just just
the idea of like well one option is
waiting 20 years
not my favorite no terrible option uh
the better option is for you to take
control of this and get rid of this in
way under 20 years and you can do it
so the 235 000 I'm assuming it's made up
of a bunch of smaller loans
I have about 30 000 in private and the
rest is all federal okay but they're
made up of a ton of loans there's other
like a dozen or more loans involved here
or is it a few big ones
it's a bunch of small ones yes okay so
here's what to do to help you have some
peace about this instead of staring at
the mountain let's break this up into
little chunks so lay them all out from
smallest to largest and we're going to
start attacking the small one first
that's baby step two baby step one
thousand bucks in the bank I assume you
have that already
I do how much other money do you have
sitting around that's liquid
uh that's liquid
maybe Seven Grand great that's gonna
knock out the credit card and probably
one of the smallest student loans the
next smallest one
yeah yeah I could see that boom we
already have some progress don't we
Mackenzie we didn't need Biden yeah
uh listen Mackenzie
um here's the uncomfortable truth about
the situation you're in is a big old
hole
and there is not going to be some night
on a white horse coming to save you on
this one
there's just not and so all George and I
were talking about this earlier off air
I
there is this moment when I want
something else to be true so bad and
this can be any number of things this
could be like I wanted my dad to live
forever and he passed away I wanted this
relationship with my romantic partner to
go forever and they stepped out on me
like these things this happens all
throughout our life
and the we gotta grieve this thing that
we hoped for that we wanted to happen
that didn't happen and then we have to
ask ourselves okay what are we gonna do
next because most of the time nobody's
coming to rescue us
and so you saying I am an electrical
engineer I'm a first gen student what
that means to me is that I've worked
with first-gen students my entire career
here's what I know about you you are
really really smart
right
thank you no no I'm not just blowing
smoke at you you're a first-gen
electrical engineering student you are
very smart correct
to the loans you took out you looked
around your classes and your classmates
were mostly dumber than you correct I
know this is a fact right
I don't know yes you do she's so humble
exactly you are correct and I think that
you're being underpaid
I think you can make more money than
seventy thousand dollars you might not
be at the most comfortable firm right
now or you might like I really want to
be doing these kind of buildings instead
of these kind of buildings right now
we're gonna take a few years and we're
gonna go for money we're gonna work
really hard to make a great salary and
we're going to get this thing paid off
and I'm telling you from a guy that has
six figures of student loan debt myself
on the other side of this you will be an
Unstoppable force in anything you do
you get what I'm saying because here's
what I think I think there's some shame
wrapped up in this like how can I be so
smart and so dumb at the same time and I
want you to put that down the whole
system preys on first gen students
there absolutely is
the good news is you are among 43
million other people who feel the same
way so you're not even special
snowflake like we all call it right so
there's a lot of people in this together
the difference is you're gonna be the
one who gets out and doesn't wait on
someone else to save the day and make no
mistake this will be awful
your friends are gonna be buying fancy
cars and you're gonna be in the same
stupid car and you're still not gonna
have a home two or three years from now
because you're still going to be paying
this off and all of your family who
didn't go to college is gonna be like
McKenzie you did all this work why
aren't you buying this and why aren't
you dressed like this because they have
a picture of success that is not based
in reality and if they're not the ones
paying your student loan bills that's
right
so they don't get a say so you commit to
this in front of a couple I don't know
10 15 million people will you commit I'm
I'm done with this I'm gonna I'm gonna
knock it out
absolutely yes dude we'll we will walk
with you every step of the way I want
you to hang on the line I'm going to
send you a copy of here we're gonna send
you a bunch of stuff I'm gonna send you
a copy of Total Money Makeover the book
and we're gonna put you in Financial
Peace University and give you a year
subscription to every dollar and it's
the it's the premium budgeting app that
we all use it's just it's first class
it's the best there is and it's going to
teach you the the step by step by step
process on how to get out of this thing
forever and as a first gen student who's
just now making big money who's I mean
you're you're going to be first gen in a
lot of different stages here and so this
program is going to help you not only
get out of debt but build wealth on the
back end too and we're going to walk
with you every step of the way in about
six months you're gonna get really
frustrated because you're gonna be
working really hard and this number's
still going to be big I want you to call
us back and we will give you another pep
talk or wherever you get stuck we'll be
here to help you along the way but this
is going to be getting roommates getting
a side job getting a different job that
pays more for your full-time gig cutting
your expenses down to nothing but then
you're gonna be able to throw 30 40
Grand at this debt and all of a sudden
you see the light at the end of the
tunnel you go three years from now four
years from now five years from now I'm
completely debt free and then we can
look at home ownership down the road and
in four years of McKenzie who has worked
your way through electrical engineering
school and paid off all their debt
there's literally no stopping her no and
go watch borrowed future if you want to
know why John and I are so riled up
about this delay dreams are on the other
side of student loans and that is why
we're angry at them you can rise above
it this is the Ramsey Show we'll be
right back
[Music]
this is the Ramsey Show triple eight
eight two five five two two five the
Ramsey Show question of the day is
sponsored by neighborly your hub for
home services from repairs and
maintenance to Remodeling and upgrades
neighborly's trusted Home Service
provides you providers have trained
local experts who can handle just about
any job so go to neighborly.com to find
and schedule service today dude I just
wear out our maintenance guys here at
the building Winston and those guys oh
yeah I need a contractor I need a deck
person you got a roofer person
neighborly Saves the Day they've got it
all man DIY more like DIY just hire a
guy yeah right that's a new tag I'm just
pitching taglines for him I don't think
they want that one I don't think that
one's free no wait here's here's the
question of the day comes from Chris in
the Ramsay baby steps community
we are on baby step two and I'm having a
hard time emptying our savings aside
from the thousand bucks to pay down debt
as our emergencies are never less than a
thousand bucks
just trying to get over this mental hump
I feel like I will be forced to charge
something like a car repair or furnace
which just happened then we'll be we'll
we will be thrown back so far I'm just
really scared I think this is the place
to focus this is more mental and
emotional that is financial correct it's
almost entirely
um and as my friend Dr Lane Norton says
data is more important than feelings a
lot of the times right so
it's easy to look back and go all these
repairs cost this much money be honest
with yourself and they they usually
don't a couple a couple times sometimes
I've had to replace a roof I had to
replace you know part of a car like they
can be expensive most of the time
they're not and George you can tell me
if I'm wrong but they're not designed
for that this is designed to light a
fire under you to get you running and
gunning absolutely it's not meant to
cover the big emergencies that's why we
call it a starter emergency fund and
baby step one and here's the truth if an
emergency happened what would you do if
you had a thousand bucks and it was a
1500 emergency well you'd pause the baby
steps you'd pause it and you'd stack up
cash as fast as you could in order to
cover it and then you're back on the
wagon the problem is right now you feel
like you're safe even though you owe
lenders a whole bunch of money that's
the confusing part to me is like if you
wanted safety so badly why are you
sitting there with money in the bank
while owing people money
to me true safety true Freedom comes on
the other side of being completely debt
free and not owing anyone anything to
where if everything went down and I know
John you like to think about this
scenario I gotta play it man a wing
don't want anything is the best way to
go it's it's just total freedom that's
right it's total freedom I don't want it
the government telling me what's it stop
owing people money I don't want my boss
to stop owing people money right it's
super simple you have more options and
so on Saturday you're coming in at eight
o'clock actually no I'm not I'm actually
not coming at eight o'clock I've got
other stuff with my family and you can
make that choice you don't owe anybody
any money right so it's just total
freedom so you can do this again it's I
like being a little bit scared because
it fuels me to get rid of this debt once
and for all and stop playing the game
and it takes something that drastic yeah
in order to get there and let Chris let
me affirm you
um I work here and a thousand dollars in
one in a in a savings account would
would I would not be able to sleep I
would be so terrified I got two little
kids I got a like wife I wouldn't be
able to breathe and that's kind of the
point
I would be so paranoid that I would be
delivering pizzas at night and driving
people to uh ubering before work in the
morning I would be so maniacal about
getting this thing knocked out so that I
could get this this savings account up
and that is the point most people don't
take us seriously when we say gazelle
intense that's an animal running for its
life because it's about to be ripped
apart and torn apart and eaten and
killed and that's the level of intensity
we want people to have and so I'm With
You Chris if I had a thousand bucks in a
savings account that was it I would not
be able to breathe and that's the point
that's the point so let this fear drive
you to none of us are eating out
nobody's getting new shoes none of us
are going to the movies we're cutting
all the subscriptions we're getting rid
of everything so we can get this crap
done so that Mama and Dad can sleep
again that's right all right let's go
out to Marissa in Richmond what's up
Marissa how we doing
Hi how are y'all all right how are you
good what's up
um yeah I had a question about um 53 and
my husband's 54 and we did Financial
Peace University about 15 years ago but
now our kids have both finished college
and we're just trying to figure out what
to do so we don't have very much money
in retirement we only have about ninety
thousand dollars each
and we do have five houses two of which
are paid off and three we have mortgages
on we rent them all out
so we're just trying to decide should we
try to pay off the mortgages or should
we throw money into our IRAs and do that
makeup and you know put as much away as
we can for that
okay so you're essentially using these
rental homes as a replacement for your
401k
currently yeah that that was right the
intent yes and that can work what's the
net profit of these properties currently
per year
um well they let's see I didn't write
that down on my list that's so great
George she's like what's some good
homework make any money do that tonight
that's some good homework for you but
here's why I asked my hunch my hunch is
that you should sell one of these right
your least favorite rental property and
use it to pay off the others or sell two
of them and pay off the others to where
you have you have a fully paid for Real
Estate portfolio to where you get to
keep 100 of that profit
and it'll lower your expenses
and once you do that then I would start
shoveling money into retirement accounts
which you have some great catch-up
contributions you can make after 50.
right yeah but you don't think my only
hesitation about that is then
is it bad if we don't have the
deductions for the rental properties
because you know the deductions are not
what's going to save your butts in
retirement
you're you're stepping over a dollar to
pick up a quarter
and so that's that's not like a wealth
hack just to use the deductions that you
can't live off of that in retirement
what you can live off of is having very
little expenses and so you can make six
grand a month and be okay because you
don't need to cover 10.
so that's that's where I would want to
be in retirement is have as few expenses
as possible paid for home paid for
rental property and a pile of money in
Investments I think that's a
well-rounded portfolio
okay so however you guys want to go
about paying off the debt is great but
it sounds like right now you're feeling
the pinch with retirement I would want
more cash flow to funnel into retirement
which means getting some of these rental
properties uh to getting rid of the
mortgages on them and George in some
ways Marissa and her husband just just
went about this backwards right most
people will fund their Roth IRAs they'll
fund another IRA and then if they've got
money left over they'll start thinking
about buying rental properties they just
went ahead and bought rental properties
and so we're going to sell a couple of
them get clear the debt and so they're
gonna have their primary house maybe two
maybe three other houses that are
completely free and clear theirs and
then they're going to start backfilling
that yeah and some people I mean they're
clearly very comfortable with real
estate which is awesome yeah we love
real estate yeah pretty much Dave's
entire portfolio and he's worth hundreds
of millions of dollars is just real
estate and mutual funds right it's that
boring and it's and he's that wealthy so
you tell me he's not at work on Friday
that's all I'm saying we're here that's
right what are we doing wrong John but
it's a great question and lot of people
are wondering well I should get into the
real estate investment game here's when
we tell you too that that's a good move
you have a paid for personal residence
and you pay cash for investment property
that is an insane thing to say in
today's world I understand how
controversial that is but it's also the
right way to do it to reduce risk and
maximize your wealth and the question is
always would you take a loan against
your personal house to buy a rental
property nobody would don't tempt
America with a good time they might do
that that's a great idea I'll take out
the HELOC use that as the down payment
these are the wealth strategies that you
find on social media these days and it's
all from Real Estate Bros and permanent
life insurance Bros who all have a
vested interest to get you to do that
thing we don't we want you to build
wealth independently not dependent on if
this thing goes right it's all it's like
putting in a parlay bet man like you got
to make every shot what a crazy way to
live just enjoy the game yeah so that's
the way to do it and obviously I'm a big
fan of using your retirement accounts
tax advantage accounts are awesome your
401k your IRA you can become a
millionaire you invest 100 bucks a month
from 25 to 65 you're going to be a
millionaire a boring one 100 a month
boring one so don't feel like you have
to do something fancy or like doing
nothing down on real estate prob you
don't have to own real estate
Investments your whole life you can have
a paid for house and millions of dollars
in the bank
it's a Choose Your Own Adventure just
don't do something stupid and don't do
debt stay away from drugs and debt there
you go don't do drugs and don't do debt
that is the new George camel t-shirt hey
it's another hour in the books here on
the Ramsey Show and I think the guys in
the booth I want to thank you America
for listening to us we will be right
back right here on the Ramsay show
[Music]
oh
hey George camel here if you love the
show and you want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we've got a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you helpful
articles and tips on following the
Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
the newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
foreign
[Music]
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studio
it's the Ramsay show where we help
people build wealth do work they love
and have incredible relationships I'm
John deloney joined here by my good
friend George Campbell basically half
the Beatles John and George and we are
taking your calls on money life whatever
you got going on work relationships
marriage mental health whatever you got
going on we got an opinion triple eight
eight two five five two two five and
George before we go to the calls I want
to talk about this article that's out
how much money does it take to be happy
oh that's a Hot Topic so is this a hot
take on a Hot Topic it is well we we
covered something similar on Smart money
happy hour saying is there a magic
salary for happiness and a great pitch
to your own show well thank you you
should go check it out but this is a
this is actually Based on data instead
of opinions
so one study said happiness Peaks at 75
000 in income now economists say it's
higher by a lot by a lot yeah so that I
remember the data that data's been
around forever and it's kind of become
like a like a folk tale right now
inflation John like 70 grand you're poor
yeah yeah that's the that's the vibe
um all right so let's go through this
um
the question uh so it's it's hired by a
lot tell me how much more
new research from a Nobel prize-winning
Economist and fellow researchers provide
a fresh answer money does appear to
boost happiness at least for some people
up to earnings of five hundred thousand
dollars
wow okay I'm gonna go with a yes on that
one so if you make five hundred and one
thousand dollars you might be miserable
you make 4.99 you're crushing the game
so this feels almost silly John because
we went from 75 grand to half a million
dollars right
because the idea was after 75 grand you
kind of plateau happiness wise right
this is saying you plateau at 500 Grand
right it's not really accurate um and
there is I think this is important to
note there is a smaller group of people
for whom higher incomes don't make much
diff much difference for this unhappy
Group which I think George is probably
in this group it's comprised of about 15
of people the relationship between
happiness and income is different with
additional money failing to improve
their sense of well-being once they hit
about a hundred grand and so there is
just yours right people who choose
um and I use that word intentionally who
choose I'm just gonna be kind of a grump
right they're just not it's not going to
help anything but it's just the way it
is and we all know those people in our
lives well I see there's two groups of
people there's one group that
legitimately doesn't make enough money
to cover their bills and survive right
so if you're in survival mode you do
need more money I'm not gonna act like
well you can make any amount of money
and be happy sure that's true we can go
to villages in Africa and find joy that
we could not find on any Street Corner
in America that is true there's another
group of people who actually make good
money but they have piles of debt and
they're overspending and they're keeping
up with the joint Jones is they're not
content with who they are and no amount
of money can fix that on one hand or
that dollar amount has become their
scorecard for their for their self-worth
and it keeps moving I have to make this
two hundred thousand dollars or I'm a
loser and my dad's never gonna tell me
he's proud of me and my wife's Gonna
Leave me and then you get 200 000 you
realize oh my life is exactly the same
way it was before I could just I have a
nicer toaster and a cooler blender and
then it moves on you well I need to take
300th and it just keeps moving and
moving and moving and moving well and
there's there's also a piece of this
where you go if you make three four
hundred thousand dollars you might have
a very stressful job that might kill you
early yeah I'll never forget that was
one of the most important lessons I
learned young um I had a mentor who
allowed me to follow it to Shadow him
and some some pretty important meetings
and I remember leaving going oh he makes
way more than me and he earns that money
like his life is hard man because just
all the stuff he's responsible for and
so yeah there's they don't hand out two
or three or four hundred thousand
dollars you got to work for that money
and it's a hard life but even then I
like working really hard I like working
really hard I like working long hours
and I like making great money but I have
to know that that is not going to
when I look in the mirror I'm not it's
not going to give me peace right what's
going to give me peace is really
extraordinary relationships a great
marriage good relationships with
relationships with my kids right healthy
balance with the seasons of work
sometimes they're wild but sometimes I
get some more family time that's going
to give me a piece of life and
the more money you make the more money
you can give away and we don't talk
about that enough there are some
extraordinary
um generosity that happens with people
who make great money well and science
shows that people who give are more
joyful that's right they have lower
blood pressure that's right they have
less stress in their lives they're more
fulfilled and so there's a lot of
components to this but I think the main
teaching that I Come Away with is saying
if you're in debt get out of debt and
see if that increases your happiness
regardless of your income number two
find a career that you actually enjoy
versus trying to aim at a certain number
and going I'm willing to do whatever job
it takes to make 200 Grand a year you
might be miserable right and some people
might be better off working for 50 Grand
a year doing something they love with no
debt hanging around them that's right
that person can be way happier than
someone making 5x app and if you are
miserable at 75 grand chances are you're
gonna be miserable at 250 Grand you go
with you that's right and so if you
don't actually dig into the roots of
that and you know like your book own
your past change your future and dig
into the trauma and the shame and the
baggage and the reasons you're trying to
do all this then no money will be enough
and we see this data on this people who
make 250 Grand are living paycheck to
paycheck so don't ever say to yourself
well if I just made 250 Grand my life
would be better you might have lifestyle
creep and you might think in a nicer
house because now you have to keep up
that's right and so there's a lot of
lessons to be learned here but what I
always go back to is the baby steps work
regardless of if you make 50 Grand or
300 Grand living debt free and having an
emergency fund of the bank will give you
a happier life and that's one component
you still have to have good
relationships good Community have a job
that you enjoy that doesn't add stress
to your life so we don't want you to
have a flat tire in any specific area of
life you got to be well-rounded yeah
well I I I I love that this um folklore
this this myth has been busted right and
I also love that we can have a
conversation
man getting to a number and thinking
that's a Finish Line is just not how the
life works it can help it can help and I
think it's good that we can now be a
little less dishonest if you will 200
000 bucks can solve a lot of problems it
can make your life easier but it won't
your dad's not going to call you if you
hadn't called you yet he's not going to
call you and say you know what now I'm
proud right yeah um you're not going to
have a dysfunctional marriage and
suddenly your wife's gonna go ah there
we go now it's better it's just not how
that works right
um
hmm so let me ask you this George
instead I was going to take another call
but I'm not gonna do that
um smart man
on on Smart money happy hour
with this particular conversation what
kind of feedback did you get
uh well the comment section was Spirited
as usual John uh one person said
George's comedy is underrated I
appreciate that
um but a lot of people
said you know what that's true because
they've realized that their income is
one factor it's one piece of the
equation we say your income is your
greatest wealth building tool we don't
say it's your joy building tool
yeah exactly and so it's one piece of
the equation when we get our money right
it allows us to look up and focus on
relationships and sleep better at night
which then gives us a better life so get
your money right and that's the
foundation you can use to fix the other
areas excellent hey triple eight eight
two five five two two five this is the
Ramsay show we'll be right back
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
I am in Little Rock what's up Sam
what's up guys how we doing
very well how are y'all outstanding
outstanding what's up
so I'm looking for wisdom on you called
the wrong show my brother wrong show
it's so wrong that I immediately busted
out laughing all right sweet uh yeah you
know my wife and I have been paying off
debt for about 14 months
and next week when our paychecks hit
we're done with that and the week after
that uh when my bonus hits we're done
with baby step three yeah so
I I'm just looking for that the mindset
that you know y'all had when
when you got done paying off that right
like what does that look like
well we say you move from intensity to
intentionality once you hit baby step
four and so there's not a lot that
changes as far as your habits of you're
still on a budget
you just let your foot off the gas as
far as you know working three jobs
because you had to to get to safety you
made it to Shore and so now the goal is
how do we start building towards the
future instead of paying for the past
and there's a lot of things you can kind
of put on autopilot like 15 into your
retirement at that point
that that can be an easy thing to do it
can also be really hard because you now
want to use that money but it still has
an allocation it still has to go
somewhere and go to work for you but
now's the time to actually go okay what
are some spending goals we have we
haven't been able to do that for a while
where do we want to go on vacation hey
it's time to upgrade that car let's do
that home renovation and cash flow it
and so that's where you sit down with
your spouse and really start to put
those goals on paper and make that a
part of your daily monthly yearly
routines so one of the things I've seen
people do Sam that helps them be
successful is it's so wise that you're
thinking through this now usually what
happens is people become debt free they
scream and yell and jump up and down in
the living room they wake up the next
morning and their lives are exactly the
same there's not many bills next month
and then they kind of Go Bananas they go
crazy and they don't maybe they'll go
back into debt but they kind of blow the
budget and just go out to eat and go to
bananas and then they start to figure
out like oh crap what do we got to do
you get you guys are a couple months
ahead of that here's where you get to do
and I want you to shift from survival to
fun I would love for you and your wife
to go out and have a long really really
nice dinner like an obnoxious one and
with the intention of what do we want
our lives to look like in the next two
to three years and what do we want our
lives to look like in fifth let's just
dream and be silly about it we want a
house here and we want the East Wing to
look like this like let's start dreaming
together not just surviving together and
then what you do is you sit down and say
okay here's what's going to take to get
there and some of these things are silly
some of them are real and we're going to
begin to build a path that's going to
get us there but now we're building a
path looking forward we're not just
running through the night to not get
eaten by a lion you see the difference
there
yeah but yeah I do here's what's really
important you have to intentionally
change your identity our identity was we
are a couple who will do whatever it
takes to get out of debt and if you
don't go through some sort of ritual if
you will to change your identity one of
you is going to hang on to that identity
and the other one's gonna get really fed
up and frustrated they can't buy new
shoes and then you're gonna have this
weird angst in the house you're not
gonna know where it's coming from it's
because you got two competing identities
in the same marriage and so let's turn
our identity who do we want to become
now do you want to be wild generous
people do we want to have our kids pay
half of their college or 100 of their
college or want to pay our house off now
we can start dreaming about whatever
comes next and it's incredible if you
guys can make that turn
yeah that makes sense did when you're
looking at like you fund money and all
that are you taking are you making
separate pots of money for that like I
just I just haven't had it so I don't it
just becomes a line item in your budget
so it's Sam's fun money okay there's an
entertainment there's a vacation sinking
fund so we save up five grand for that
trip six months from now and so that's
all it becomes and I have different
areas there you go and do three things
with money give it save it spend it I
like to do it in that order so set
giving goals that's going to come off
the top set some savings goals so we're
gonna invest 15 we're gonna save up for
the car we're gonna save up for the
vacation and then have some spending
goals and go all right we're gonna spend
some money this month we're gonna set it
500 bucks to go out to eat because we
just haven't been able to do that we got
to catch up on all the new restaurants
in Little Rock whatever it is for you
guys but doing that helps me feel
grounded and not like I'm leaning one
way too much because some people go I
have to save save save save I can't
spend a dime Dave said no Dave didn't
say that he said live like no one now so
later you can live and give like no one
else and it's time to start leaning into
the ladder I think um
I would maybe do it for a couple of
months at a time Sam I just said two to
three years maybe say hey we're gonna
spend two months and we're just gonna go
to some restaurants we're gonna eat out
because we haven't done that in so long
and this we're just gonna enjoy some of
these restaurants what you will find is
it will be nice and cool and you're
gonna look forward to going back to
eating at home
and okay you're gonna like somebody else
doing the dishes and it's going to feel
good to have somebody else clean up
after you and then you're gonna get
tired of the 50 and 60 and 70 dollar
bills just at regular old restaurants
these days and you're gonna say ah I'd
rather go back home right so it's just
but do it do it just here's the key just
make sure you budget for it just put it
in the budget
yeah
okay
and thank you this will be wonky okay
just be if you'll have an argument you
get frustrated it's like well I had my
eye on this guitar and she's like well I
had my eye on you never buying another
guitar like those expect those things to
happen that's just marriage it's just
life that's two people doing life
together
um but you're not broken and you're not
something something's not wrong it's
just about turning the corner and
changing identities together which dude
I just think that's going to be a blast
man it's gonna be a blast all right
let's roll out to Holly in Davenport
what's up Holly how we doing
hey Dr John hey George it's good to talk
to you guys it's great to talk to you
too how we doing
yeah well speaking of changing identity
um I am a new stay-at-home mom and I do
kind of lonely and isolated
um you know I worked I worked for 20
years
um before my husband and I had kids and
I'm about a year into this thing and
it's just like I said kind of lonely
isolated and I just I want to be here
with my kids I think it's selfish it
would be very selfish of me to send my
kids to daycare so I can you know go
work we don't need the money I need to
be here with my kids but I want to find
happiness in it I want to find joy in it
and I I just can't I just haven't been
able to
[Music]
um
man
I if you were in front of me I would ask
if it's okay to give you a hug because I
this this is one of the most common
conversations I have across the country
and it's the opposite I have the
opposite conversation as well
um I can't stay at home and I feel like
I should or or I should be at work I
want to be at work and I feel like I got
to be at home and then I my kids do
something crazy and then I think mean
thoughts like I wish my kids would stop
smearing crap all of it and then I feel
guilty for having these thoughts and so
I want you to understand you've entered
and you've been in it for a long time
um but you are continuing in to the
vortex that is modern Western world
that is built on a guilt Factory for
mothers you can't wait and if you do
damned that's right you're gonna get
judgment on either side and opinions
from the other moms yes you're and
you're going to get opinions from
yourself
that's the issue that I'm having you
know I can care less about the outside
world and honestly I I think maybe some
of the issue too is that I I don't
really have Community I don't have a lot
of friends I think family doesn't live
here I think that is
um key here's two things I think are key
number one I think you thought it would
feel different
if I make this huge sacrifice the reward
that I'm going to quote unquote feel
inside is going to be worth it and that
feeling's not there but but you did get
a great feeling from being really good
at your professional job and getting a
paycheck deposit in your account and
getting getting out of girls from your
from your co-workers and your
supervisors that felt awesome it was
built-in validation yeah every day it
doesn't feel awesome and when you make
it a great meal and your kids are like I
don't like this it's gross or Timmy
pushed me and you're like how about I
push you off you know so number one you
have to every time you have those
feelings just call them out
I thought this was gonna feel
differently and I feel like I want to
karate chop somebody I'm not going to
but I feel it the second thing is you
nailed it you gotta get a group of women
in your life and that's the hard weird
ugly annoying part it's almost like
dating again except harder you got to
make a choice to get some women in your
life
um Tessa Romero check her out on
Instagram Tessa Romero she's great with
Mom new mom's mindset shift she's
awesome and um make it a point to get
some friends you're worth it this is the
Ramsey Show we'll be right back
foreign
[Music]
hey what's happening this is the Ramsey
Show I'm John deloney joined by my good
friend George camel and on the debt-free
stage we have Anna and Isabella and
Nicholas what is happening hey happy to
be here how we doing good all the way
from the great state the only country
that matters Texas that's right very
cool all right so you're here from Texas
and you're doing your debt free screams
how much do we pay off I paid off thirty
eight thousand four hundred and seventy
three dollars
38 470.
um making how much so I started with 54
000 and ended at 98 000. is that just
you yeah just me what do you do
so I work for say and I do sales for
power distribution equipment and the
first year of my
debt-free snowball I did Uber and I sold
cookies and I also sold everything
that's a lot of cool you had a third kid
and they're gone too yeah it's gone so
how long did it take to pay this off 21
months amazing oh so you got after it
after it after it yeah especially the
first year
so what kind of debt was the 38 000. it
was credit cards car
um AC repairs some chairs
and some chairs yeah my dining chairs
Wow Come on was that because of like
it's a zero percent or was that you were
so broken like I gotta get chairs and
put them on the car like how did that
work
it was a really good deal
[Laughter]
for the honesty it's such a good deal it
was after my divorce so I needed chairs
mine were falling apart and so I got
them on like PayPal for paint on
payments wow so it took me a few months
and it took a few months for the chairs
to get here too so all right 21 months
ago
um you're sitting by yourself in
Montgomery Texas and you've got these
two kids and they're sleeping and you've
got your heads ahead and your hands yeah
and you say it's time what tell us about
what happened so
my debt-free snowball started in 2021
okay but I heard about the snowball in
2017 or 2019 was I was still married
and we had
we were so normal we had all the debt
all the credit cards and every time we
would get a chunk of money
at bonus
uh
taxes whatever we would pay off a credit
card and then we would start paying off
the other and by the time we got paid
paid off the other we already racked up
on that one you collected some more so
it was a vicious cycle
and then
I remember sitting down that year 2017
2018 and I just Googled how to pay off
credit cards because I was raised to
never use credit and so I was raised to
live and listen I make on saving money
that's insane animal it's insane and I
went to college that free too like I
worked my butt off but
um somewhere along the way we started
racking off that and
I wasn't taught how to like pay it off I
mean I didn't know you know we had so
much that it was it just seemed
impossible so I remember sitting down in
my dining table
on the dining chairs no no no I was
married I was married yeah good
um and so
because it wasn't me now you figure it
out
and so I just started like Googled how
to pay credit cards and it was all this
um you know debt consolidation move your
credit cards to this card and I was like
that makes no sense
and a few pages
you know took that far to get to a range
pages to get to Ramsay and all they said
is like snowball and I read it and it
makes sense
and so I presented it to my ex-husband
now and nothing happened we just kept
living the way we were living and then
2020 happened
and
um
my marriage was falling apart and
I lost my job
oh no
and then
um
my dad passed away
and
um so in the summer of 2020 I filed for
divorce and I got a job the job that I
have now
annual sales so I just knew that this
guy is the limit and I started with a
base
um
base salary and then
it just went up from there but it took a
while and so I filed for divorce and
three months later it was finalized and
on paper
you know like in my head
I could afford things like I could
afford my house and I could afford I
changed my cars I downsized
um and I was totally okay with that
but in my head it would I could afford
my house payment and groceries and just
the basic things and even the minimum
payments on my credit card and then I
couldn't and so
things in those six months between my
divorce being finalized and
when I started
there were weeks where I had like eight
dollars to my name wow wow that's
terrifying right it is yeah so you went
from an emotional crawl to a financial
Sprint yeah and how do you even do that
I'm just
that's just the kind of person I am I go
from zero to a hundred and like no time
wow so you're a hero okay so what does
it feel like now it's great I love it
like I'm never going back I like
whenever you whenever you go home and
you watch the clip of this yeah I want
you to watch your body language because
when you tell your story about
your body remembers your marriage
falling apart your dad passing away your
whole body shrinks and then just asking
you how does it feel now it's like
somebody turned all the lights on in the
lobby out there yeah I mean I tell
everyone like don't
stop living the way that you are because
everyone right now is normal
and you know I did like a no spend
February because I was like I'm tired of
this and I remember I had 300 and I was
like oh my gosh this is so awesome I
have 300 without even having a budget
and then I downloaded every dollar app
in March and I kind of toyed around with
that going back to my bank statements
like December January and even February
and I said my budget and April it was on
and
um how did you get these two little ones
to follow with you
oh I mean if I did ubereats they were in
the car with me oh fantastic so they got
to see Mom hey you have given them a
legacy shifting gift because they're
never gonna forget that and in college
someone's gonna offer be like hey let's
just go get a credit card week and
you're gonna be like no I remember
driving around with my mom I wasn't shy
about talking to them about the money
problems I mean I didn't you know I
didn't
um
burden them but I did share like no
we're not doing this because you know
we're gonna do this we did go to
birthday parties but instead of bringing
the flashy gift I brought like a token
for frozen yogurt yeah and a handmade
card and a handmade bag or whatever and
so that's how we they contributed and it
was a lot of nails well more is caught
than taught and what they caught from
watching Mom be a hero is gonna sit with
them for the rest of their lives I hope
so without going on the college campus
going here kid here's a here's a credit
card and free pizza he's gonna stick on
that game like no absolutely I saw my
mom fight to get over this but I also
need you to know this there are millions
of single parents watching this right
now yeah and they can't breathe and they
got two little kids and their world's
falling apart and then mom calls and
says dad's not doing well and you have
single-handedly shined a light in a
really dark moment we can all sit up
here and talk and they're like oh it's
real easy for you guys to
and Anna you've taken away the darkness
in so many lives by just saying no more
no more no more you know I hate the
spotlight but the fact the sharing my
story and I know that there's a single
parent out there Mom or Dad lots of them
that are going through this and they
don't see the light and I didn't see the
light you're an inspiration and all you
need is the process and it works
Isabella and Nicholas your mom's a
gangster you know never to mess with her
correct oh yeah excellent that's awesome
well we've got the living give box for
you uh that includes The Total Money
Makeover of course baby steps
millionaires your next chapter and your
story and a year of Financial Peace
University so that you can kick-start
someone else's Journey thank you and you
give it away all right so we've got 38
470 bucks paid off in 21 months making
30 54 to 98 000 dollars
From the Ashes the Phoenix Rose and here
she is standing before us paid us all
off it's time to do your debt free
screen let's Let It Rip
one oh no three two one where then
awesome
I wish my mom was that cool back then
you know what a hero
I love my favorite part of the show is
debt free screams especially the
excuse Busters yeah but I have yeah but
I have
yeah but I know Anna
nothing or not I know Anna not with her
finances not with her career not with
nothing if you are listening to this no
one can stop you either if you just say
today's the day
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Laughter]
thank you
[Music]
today's scripture of the day is Matthew
5 14-15 you are the light of the world
a town built on a hill cannot be hidden
neither do people light a lamp and put
it under a bowl instead they put it on
its stand and get and it gives light to
everyone in the house
brene Brown says numb the dark and you
numb the light
numb the dark and you numb the light I
love that love that love that all right
let's go out to Richard in Jacksonville
Florida what's up Richard
hey how's it going outstanding how are
you
doing great
um so basically so I've been kind of
following Dave Ramsey since 2013 where I
actually read this book I'm in the Coast
Guard and actually that's when I got
introduced to it very cool my dad got me
the book and um you know I've been
trying to follow those baby steps as
best as possible my question to you all
is we're about to uh PCS over to Puerto
Rico okay and um we live near
Jacksonville Florida and
um we're not sure if we should be
selling our house or renting it we do
owe a little bit on it but it is mostly
paid off uh we know that we could sell
it for 300 000 or about 300 000 and uh
or rent it out for about two thousand
dollars a month uh we owe 76 on it at a
2.87 percent uh conventional loan
um and we bought it for 215. so
basically in three years we got it down
to 76. way to go
um so how long are you going to be in
Puerto Rico
it's going to be for three years and our
housing and utilities are going to be
included because we're going to be
government housing so we don't have to
worry about any payments so basically I
can get straight to step six because I
won't have no house if I were to sell
however it could be an income stream
um especially with the low interest rate
and then I'm totally against it I don't
have any other debt
um so this is pretty much what I'm
working with
so I I'm going to answer you what I
would do if this is just my family and
George can give you a more numbers
driven answer
um I would not want to be a landlord
on the other side of the world
um and I know other side of the world is
relative here but I would want to be a
landlord one state over when the dealing
with a company that's going to come in
and manage the property or when the air
conditioner goes out or the dishwasher
leaks and causes uh the floor subfloor I
just want to deal with that I'd much
rather have cash in a um just a regular
money market account if you will let it
sit there throw it in a Vanguard account
for a few years and just let it sit so
that when we come back to the States and
quite honestly Puerto Rico is incredible
if you come back to the States
um then you can buy a place and you come
back and would you for sure be stationed
back in Jacksonville when you came back
uh no so it will actually likely not be
back in Jacksonville all right for sure
so I'm actually from Puerto Rico okay
that's home for me but um it'll probably
be who knows right likely probably
Washington DC is my guess okay yeah then
I'm I'm selling and here's another
option for you Richard when you if you
do sell it let's say you net 200 Grand
is that fair to say after fees
sure if you just park that 200 Grand in
a high yield savings account which right
now we're tracking at about four percent
you would make eight grand a year
guaranteed
and so when you look at renting this
place out even for two grand you still
have expenses Property Management you've
got to pay the mortgage you may not even
net the eight grand in a year
and so I'm taking the hassle factor out
of here knowing you're not going to come
back I'm going to sell it and I know
your word because the interest rate is
so good but you're gonna be in a
different place when you come back
financially emotionally mentally
physically where you're located so I'm
selling this thing if I'm in your shoes
absolutely
okay does this sound good let's see
sounds like a very straightforward
answer there you go that's all you get
out of it I know I know it sounds so
cool to be like I'm a landowner and I've
got a rental property back it it's free
money but man it feels really good to
have a couple hundred thousand dollars
in a bank account too I mean especially
with the interest rates right now in
savings accounts yeah they're doing
they're doing it you can do better there
than you can dealing with a renter when
you've got a mortgage on the place Hey
when's the last time you were excited
about a Monday can't remember oh that
was rhetorical that was what you're
talking about what if instead of waking
up exhausted you felt exhilarated you
can't wait to get to work because it's
another day to fulfill your passion in a
world where there's bare minimum Monday
and there's quiet quitting it's clear
people are craving meaningful work but
finding the career you were born to do
can be difficult when you don't have the
right tools that's why career expert in
Ramsay personality Ken Coleman created
the get clear career assessment to help
you discover your top talents passions
and a clear mission statement that'll
help you find the work the world needs
you to do after taking the quick
assessment you'll get a custom Report
with everything you need to take that
first step towards a meaningful career
go to
ramseysolutions.com get clear to start
your journey and take the get clear
assessment today that's
ramseysolutions.com
get clear all right let's go out to Salt
Lake City Utah and talk to Carlos what's
up Carlos
dude
I never thought that would be on the on
on this show so I'm big fans of you guys
um I have a question so me and my
brothers we own a plumbing and HVAC
business
and um we're having a little a little
issue with um with pay so we're able to
to pay ourselves
um and our company like during the our
busiest season is between may all the
way to the probably around November and
we did 1.1 million
but the slow season December January
February and March were like we're
barely swinging by we lost one employee
because we couldn't keep him that busy
so my question is is should we
just take out like a line of credit
to pay ourselves and because we still
got to pay our master plumber and we
have to pay
um
accountants and we still got to pay
truck payments we have I think one one
or two truck payments
so hold on do you have enough work are
y'all making enough money you have
enough business cash flow to pay your
bills
yeah uh
um do you have any debt on the business
currently
the only thing that we have is a is two
trucks on there we have a loan for two
trucks what's that amount to
that amounts to eighteen thousand okay
I don't think the solution here is to go
into debt to keep the business afloat
and that problem is going to continue
compounding the better solution is to
figure out either how do we have enough
Revenue to cover those months that were
down or even better how do we find even
a different line of work where we can
make this sustainable December through
March to bring in some Revenue
but I would not take a line of credit to
pay yourselves
you're if you do that brother you're
digging a hole that one slow month will
bear you man
you end up having to sell a truck to
make uh the the line of credit payment
and you're gonna find yourself in a mess
it will eventually tank your business to
go this route
so I actually go to the root of the
problem and fix that which is we got to
figure out how do other businesses
create Revenue December through March
is that your is that is that are those
the months that you're struggling
yeah so December through March um April
the end of April is when we kind of
start getting a little bit busy it
starts getting a little warmer okay
people so yeah that's usually our our
busiest season so here's what I would
recommend you do Carlos I would
recommend you
take two or three guys in in Salt Lake
City who are plumbers that you trust
that have been doing this for a while
take them out for coffee
just business owner business owner
and say hey what do you guys do between
December and April just asking you
straight like we are we're running slow
and the the the annoying word here is
vulnerability it's getting a couple
people you trust and just saying hey
times are rough these four months and
we're starting to think about other
ideas for revenue streams during these
months what does that look like for
y'all and some of them will laugh at you
at some of them so you just take out a
line of credit all right cool great
those are off the table for me what's
another idea and then you're going to
get to some really
um ingenious ideas small business owners
are some of the most creative people in
the world because they have to be right
I know landscaping companies that hang
up Christmas lights during the winter
time because they can't mow lawn and
they rake leaves and they pick up sticks
and they'll make great money exactly but
but it's a way to just keep the thing
going over time so Carlos uh the bottom
line here is don't put your small
business in further Jeopardy by tying
its its success to a bank you don't need
any more voices in there man sit down
with some folks get some ideas sit down
with your team and get some ideas and
let's roll forward hey that's it for the
Ramsey Show today I want to thank James
and Ben and Ebu and the crew out in the
booth and I want to thank you America
for listening to the show George great
show Good Times man you're getting
better at this appreciate it appreciate
you and everybody listen and take care
of each other be kind and let that
person on the highway next to you let
them over the whole world will be better
for it we'll see you soon
[Music]
thank you
hey it's Dr John deloney if you like
what you heard in this episode and want
to know more about getting started on
the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramseysolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramsesolutions.com and click get started